my parents gave me an extraordinary name
baratunde a Rafiq thurston now Berra
tunde's based on a Yerba name from
nigeria but we're not Nigerians that's
just how black my mama was get this boy
the black is name possible what does the
book say Rafiq is an Arabic name but we
are not Arabs my mom just wanted me to
have difficulty boarding planes in the
21st century she foresaw America's turns
for nativism she was a black futurist
Thurston is a British name but we are
not British shout out to the
multi-generational dehumanizing economic
institution of American chattel slavery
though also Thurston makes for a great
Starbucks named really expedites the
process
my mother was a Renaissance woman Anita
Lorraine Thurston was a computer
programmer former domestic worker
survivor of sexual assault an artist and
an activist she prepared me for this
world with lessons in black history in
martial arts in urban farming and then
she sent me in the seventh grade to the
private Sidwell Friends School where US
presidents send their daughters and
where she sent me looking like this I
had two key tasks going to that school
don't lose your blackness and don't lose
your glasses this accomplished both
[Applause]
Sidwell was a great place to learn the
arts and the sciences but also the art
of living amongst whiteness that would
prepare me for life later at Harvard or
doing corporate consulting or for my
jobs at the Daily Show and the onion I
would write down many of these lessons
in my memoir how to be black which if
you haven't read yet makes you a racist
because we've had plenty of time to read
the book but America insists on
reminding me in teaching me what it
means to be black in America it's
December 2018 I'm with my fiance in the
suburbs of Wisconsin we're visiting her
parents both of whom are white which
makes her white that's how it works I
don't make the rules
she's had some drinks so I drive us in
her parents car and we get pulled over
by the police I'm scared I turn on the
flashing lights to indicate compliance I
pull over slowly under the brightest
streetlight I can find in case I need
witnesses or dashcam footage we get out
my identification their car registration
lay it out in the open roll down the
windows my hands are placed on the
steering wheel all before the officer
exits the vehicle this is how to stay
alive as we wait I think about these
headlines police shoot another unarmed
black person and I don't want to join
them the good news is our officer was
friendly
she told us our tags were expired so to
all the white parents out there if your
child is involved with a person whose
skin tone is rated Dwayne the rock
Johnson or darker
you need to get that car inspected
update the paperwork every time we visit
that's just common courtesy I got lucky
I got a law enforcement professional I
survived something that should not
require survival and I think about this
series of stories police shoot another
unarmed black person and that season
when those stories popped up everywhere
I would scroll through my feed and I
would see a baby announcement photo I'd
see an ad for a product I had just
whispered to a friend about yesterday I
would see a video of a police officer
gunning down someone who looked just
like me and I'd see a think piece about
how Millennials have replaced sex but
avocado toast it was a confusing time
those stories kept popping up but in
2018 those stories got changed out for a
different type of story stories like
white woman calls cops on black woman
waiting for an uber that was Brooklyn
Becky then there was white woman calls
police on eight-year-old black girl
selling water that was permit patty then
there was woman calls police on black
family barbecuing at Lake in Oakland
that was the now-infamous barbecue Becky
and I contend that these stories of
living while black are actually progress
we used to find out after the
extrajudicial police killings now we're
getting video of people calling 911
upstream closer to the problem and
closer to the solution so I started a
collection of as many of these stories
as I could find I built an evolving
still growing database at baratunde a
calm / living while black seeking
understanding I realized the process was
really diagramming sentences to
understand these headlines and I want to
thank my Sidwell English teacher
Erica berry and all English teachers you
have given us tools to fight for our own
freedom what I found was a process to
break down the headline and understand
the consist
layers in each one a subject takes an
action against the target engaged in
some activity so that white woman calls
police on eight-year-old black girl is
the same as white man calls police on
black woman using neighborhood pool is
the same as a woman calls cops on black
org and lawmaker campaigning in her
district they are the same diagramming
the sentences allowed me to diagram the
white supremacy which allowed such
sentences to be true and I will pause to
define my terms when I say white
supremacy I'm not just talking about
Nazis or white power activists and I'm
definitely not saying that all white
people are racist what I'm referring to
is a system of structural advantage that
favors white people over others in
social economic and political arenas
it's what Brian Stevenson at the equal
justice initiative calls the narrative
of racial difference the story we told
ourselves to justify slavery and Jim
Crow and mass incarceration and beyond
so when I saw this pattern repeating I
got angry but I also got inspired to
create a game a game of words that would
allow me to transform this traumatic
exposure into more of a healing
experience I'm gonna talk you through
the game the first level is a training
level and I need your participation
our objective to determine if this is
real or fake did this happen or not
here's the example Catholic University
law librarian calls police on student
for being argumentative clap your hands
if you think this is real
clap your hands if you think this is
fake the reels have it unfortunately and
point of information being argumentative
in a law library is the exact right
place to do that
this student should be promoted to
professor training level complete so we
move on to the real levels level one our
objective is simple reverse the roles
that means woman calls cops on black
Oregon lawmaker becomes black Oregon
lawmaker calls cops on women that means
white man calls police on black woman
using neighborhood pool becomes black
woman calls police on white man using
neighborhood pool how do you like them
reverse racist apples that's it level
one complete and so we level up it's a
level to where our objective is to
increase the believability of the
reversal let's face it a black woman
calling police on a white man using a
pool isn't absurd enough but what if
that white man was trying to touch her
hair without asking hmm or maybe he was
making oat milk while riding a unicycle
or maybe he's just talking over everyone
in a meeting we've all pinned me over
hate seriously we've all been there so
that's it level to complete but it comes
with a warning simply reversing the flow
of injustice is not justice that is
vengeance that is not our mission that's
a different game so we level up to level
three where the objective is to change
the action also known as calling the
police is not your only option oMG what
is wrong with you people and I need to
pause the game to remind us of the
structure a subject takes an action
against the target engaged in some
activity white woman calls police on
black real estate investor inspecting
his own property California Safeway
calls cops on black woman donating food
to the homeless golf club twice calls
cops on black women for playing too slow
in all these cases the subject is
usually white the target is usually
black and the activities are anything
from sitting in a Starbucks to using the
wrong type of barbeque - napping -
walking agitated on the way to work
which I just call walk into work and my
personal favorite not stopping his dog
from humping her dog which is clearly a
case for dog police not people police
all of these activities add up to living
our existence is being interpreted as
crime now this is the obligatory moment
in the presentation where I have to say
not everything is about race crime is
the thing should be reported but ask
yourself do we need armed men to show up
and resolve this situation because when
they show up for me it's different we
know that police officers use force more
with black people than with white people
and we are learning the role of 911s
thanks to preliminary research from the
Center for policing equity we're
learning that in some cities most of the
interaction between cops and citizens is
due to 9-1-1 calls not officer initiated
stops and most of the violence the use
of force by police on citizens is in
response to those calls further when
those officers responding to calls use
force that increases in areas where the
percentage of the white population has
also increased aka
gentrification aka unicycles and oat
milk
aka when barbecue Becky feels threatened
she becomes a threat to me in my own
neighborhood which forces me and people
like me to police ourselves required
ourselves we walk on eggshells we maybe
pull over to the side of the road under
the brightest light we can find so that
our murder might be caught cleanly on
camera and we do this
because we live in a system in which
white people can to easily call on
deadly force to ensure their comfort the
California Safeway didn't just call cops
on black woman donating food to homeless
they ordered armed unaccountable men
upon her they essentially called in a
drone strike
this is weaponized discomfort and it is
not new from 1877 to 1950 there were at
least 4,400 documented racial terror
lynchings of black people in the United
States they had headlines as well
Reverend ta Allen was lynched in
Hernando Mississippi for organizing
local sharecroppers Oliver Moore was
lynched in Edgecombe County North
Carolina for frightening a white girl
Nathan Byrd was lynched near Luling
Texas for refusing to turn his son over
to a mob we need to change the action
whether that action is lynches or calls
police and now that I have shortened the
distance between those two let's get
back to our game to our mission our
objective and level three is to change
the action so what if instead of calls
cops on black woman donating food to
homeless that California Safeway simply
thanks her thanking is far cheaper than
bringing law enforcement to the scene or
instead of you know they could give the
food they would have wasted to her up
their civic cred or the white woman who
called the police on the eight-year-old
black girl she could have but all the
inventory from that little black girl
support a small business and the white
woman who call the police and the black
real estate investor we would all be
better off the cops agree if she had
simply ignored him and minded her own
damn business
minding one's own damn business is an
excellent choice excellent choice
choose it more often level three is
complete but there is a final bonus
level where the objective is inclusion
we have also seen headlines like this
powerful man masturbates in front of
young women visiting his office what an
odd choice for powerful man to make so
many other actions available to him like
such as listens to men's horse inspired
by starch joint-venture everybody rich
now I want to live in that world of
everybody rich now but because of his
poor choice we are all in a poorer world
doesn't have to be this way this word
game reminded me that there is a
structure to white supremacy as there is
to misogyny as there is to all systemic
abuses of power structure is what makes
them systemic I'm asking people here to
see the structure where the power is in
it and even more importantly to see the
humanity of those of us made targets by
this structure I am here because I was
loved and invested in and protected and
lucky because I went to the right
schools I'm semi famous mostly happy
meditate twice a day and yet I walk
around in fear because I know that
someone seeing me as a threat can become
a threat to my life and I am tired I am
tired of carrying this invisible burden
of other people's fears and many of us
are and we shouldn't have to because we
can change this because we can change
the action which changes the story which
changes the system that allows those
stories to happen systems are just
collective stories we all buy into when
we change them we write a better reality
us all to be a part of I am asking us to
use our power to choose I am asking us
to level up thank you I am baratunde a
Rafi thirsty